the presidential election in Turkey
appears to be headed for a runoff vote
later this month so far near the
president erdogan or his opponent Kamal
kilish daralu have managed to reach the
50 vote threshold needed to secure a
victory so what is the current state of
the share of votes in turkey or
president erdogan so far has 49.4
percent of the vote while his main rival
Kamal kalish daralu has received
44.9 percent a third candidate the
Nationalist politician sinan organ
secured 5.2 percent of the votes if the
election heads for a runoff then the two
leading candidates erdogan and kilish
darelu will go head to head in two weeks
time our Europe correspondent Anna
Parsons has the latest on the situation
in Turkey for us
well this is the headquarter building of
the AK party it's president erdogan's
political movement and last night in the
small hours he appeared on the balcony
behind me proclaiming his victory well I
don't think he actually has got an
outright win in the first round we're
going to go to a second round runoff but
there's no doubt that the president will
be how much happier about this round of
voting than his Challenger Kamal coach
darolu many people had predicted that
this would be the moment of change for
turkey that erdogan's 20-year grip on
power would come to an end instead he
seems to have come out stronger in the
voting and I had to say I think some of
the air has come out of the balloon for
this Coalition of opposition passes what
has gone wrong for them well perhaps
some people were put off by the fact
that beyond the idea of getting rid of
erdogan they didn't really have anything
else that held them together probably
plenty of others looked at Irwin and
thought he is a strong stable leader who
has stood up to the west and stood up to
America a second round of voting to come
but it is erdogan who will go into that
as the favorite